Okay, the time has come to wrap up
transactions where we will cover transaction rules. And the
two things we will start with are snapshot
isolation which defines the read consistency and optimistic concurrency
which governs concurrent updates. We'll start off with
snapshot isolation. And please observe that this behavior may
differ between languages, so be sure to check out
the documentation. The first rule is that all read
operations in a transaction will return the values datastore
had when the transaction started. And the second rule
for snapshot isolation is. Updates will not be reflected
while in the transaction. So, if an entity is modified
or deleted in the transaction, a query will get
the original version of the entity, or nothing if
the entity did not exit then. That's snapshot isolation,
but please be sure to check out the documentation as
this behavior is somewhat language specific. So let's
turn to optimistic concurrency. This rule is that a
commit transaction would only be successful if the
values updated by this transaction have not changed since
the begin transaction. If the values that you're
trying to update has changed since begin, the transaction
will fail. Then there are two additional rules
you should be aware of. The first is that
one transaction can modify at most five ancestor
groups. The second rule is that a transaction
must complete within 60 seconds, but the general
rule is, of course, to keep the execution
of transactions short. As short as possible, unless
in extremely rare cases, they should be finished
within a couple of seconds and in most
cases, less than a second. That completes this section